King Arthur legend of the sword is
directed by Guy Ritchie and stars
Charlie Hunnam as young King Arthur he
was robbed of his birthright as a kid he
was picked up and raised in a brothel he
has no idea about his past until the day
he pulls the sword from the Stone and
realizes that he is in fact destined to
be King Guy Ritchie is off and on for me
I like a lot of his earlier work and I
actually really enjoyed the Sherlock
Holmes movies but I really did not like
the Man From UNCLE
and sometimes his movies are style over
substance and while I'm not like the
biggest critic of style over substance
sometimes his films really do come off
that way like a lot of really cool shots
and cinematography and that's about it
and I was really late seeing this movie
so I saw a lot of the critics reviews
and that they were pretty scathing and I
got to say after seeing it I'm really
surprised at that this movie was quite a
bit of enjoyable fun is it a great film
no it has a lot of storytelling problems
but from beginning to end I was
consistently entertained and it was a
very fast-paced and enjoyable movie Guy
Ritchie infuses his typical Guy Ritchie
energy into the film especially with the
way he edits conversations along with
the action sequences he has a great way
of weaving past events through presents
and even looking into their future and
making them all be one scene and have
all of the dialogue feels seamless he's
excellent at that and Charlie Hunnam was
awesome as King Arthur I mean he got
huge for this movie if he looked into
the making of the production you see
that he was very adamant about getting
this role despite the other competitors
who were also trying to get the role he
really really went for it and if you
read into the back story of how he told
Guy Ritchie he will do literally
anything for this role all the way up to
fighting physically Henry Cavill and Jai
Courtney that's pretty much what got in
the role according to a lot of the
making of things that I've read into
this film after seeing it and I got a
respect Charlie Hunnam Jude Law plays
the current evil king of the land and
he's really relishing this role he had a
lot of fun with it you can tell and he
was evil but it wasn't over the top like
there's some sequences in this movie
where he has to do some really
despicable things and his performance
was really good and it wasn't just like
this hilarious b-movie bad guy where he
laughs quietly in his room while he
strokes a small portion of his chin he
actually did
a job in the film Daniel Pemberton's
musical score was also very entertaining
very loud a lot of drum beats very
different for this type of film which is
perfect for a guy ritchie movie because
when i go to one of his stones i expect
a very different and off-kilter look at
something that we've seen told in films
before in this case a fantasy movie
which we've all seen tons of and lately
most of the fantasy movies have really
sucked the great wall was really bad so
it was fun to watch one that was
completely unpretentious in every way
this movie was just fun from beginning
to end and there's nothing much else to
get from it which is probably my biggest
flaw with it from a storytelling
standpoint i didn't really care much
about anything it was just visually
entertaining and all the actors were
really having a blast with their roles
and the dialogue was quick and witty but
from a storytelling standpoint there's
nothing really to grasp onto and towards
the end it gets very cgi heavy there are
sequences that rely quite a bit on cg
that do kind of take you out of the
movie although the 3d was actually
surprisingly worth it all in all King
Arthur legend of the sword is nowhere
near as bad as critics are saying and
this is yet another movie this year or
I'm just not on the same page with them
I'm gonna give king Arthur of B so guys
sorry this review was kind of late I
didn't get a chance to see it last week
or this weekend because Monday through
Friday I was working on a film
production crew here in Ohio I can't
really tell you what it's about yet but
when I can I'll tell you more
information it was a lot of fun I
learned quite a bit I met a lot of
really cool people and I can share more
of that with you but Wednesday was the
hardest day because it's 7 p.m. I had an
alien covenant screening I saw it then I
went straight from that to the film set
that I was working on and then I worked
on that all night and then I ran home
after that and reviewed alien covenant
so that was a long day but I really
wanted to get that review out for you
guys so yeah sorry for the late review
I'll give you information when I can
about the production that I worked on
and I hope to share that with you soon
guys thank you so much as always for
watching and if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]